[Musique]
au quotidien on est quand même assez
exposé on le ressent aussi dans nos
petites communes on pense qu'on est là
pour résoudre tout les problèmes mais
mais non quoi on est à l'écoute des gens
mais voilà il faut aussi nous respecter
on est là pour soutenir ce ce point là
quoi on est des personnes comme tout le
monde on fait ce qu'on
peut nous avons rencontré d'autres mères
et nous avons échangé sur ces sujets là
sur les difficultés que aussi avait par
rapport à l'exercice de leur fonction on
connait bien les maires de
l'agglomération mais dès qu'on s'éloigne
un peu dans l'Oise on ne les connaît
plus donc il faut des instants comme ça
pour pouvoir dialoguer avec eux et puis
les rencontrer c'est vraiment un moment
de partage la séance est levée et
ensuite ça a été décoré pour le mariage
de Napoléon I avec Eugénie Monti vous
avez l'histoire de France depuis le
baptême de
[Musique]
CLIS nos sénateurs sont là pour défendre
nos intérêts bien sûr et essayer de de
faire en sorte que les villages les
communes et ca vivent correctement c'est
nos correspondants direct donc il
peuvent faire remonter toutes ces
questions et témoigner pour nous devant
toute la France ils obtiennent quand
même beaucoup de choses et on les
[Musique]
remercie